okay um so the errand is flaky so we'll
see if I can get through this talk um so
as Jake so eloquently mentioned I am
Sofia and I'm here to talk to you about
memory management and JavaScript if
you're sitting in the back or you can't
see the screen or for whatever reason
you can follow along with the talk at
JMP /j s - ma'am - live and you'll just
automatically see everything but also
the internet is down so you can't it's
not moving I'm sorry guys this is no fun
it's reconnecting
is so awkward oh my god
I'm not worried I could do this thing
just without slides but that wouldn't be
fun Oh
I actually can't do this thing about
slides yes do we have Ethernet I could
tell jokes in the meantime knock-knock
King Tut King Chucky fried chicken
what does it web developers ghosts a
Twitter bootstrap I was going to come on
stage and help but you've got this rao's
the faster he works the quicker this
torture will be over let's see if I can
remember another one oh god I can't even
have any good memory bank banter what's
your what's your favorite memory address
oh my god so you see if you have you've
been able to use the chrome dev tools in
terms of memory cleanup wow you are the
only person in the world who can use
that that's amazing believe it or not um
once this is set up you guys are
actually going to be getting the
opportunity to interact with the chrome
dev tools a bit more I created a
tutorial an interactive tutorial for
everyone at the conference to follow
along with to learn how to use dev tools
I always find that it's one of the
reasons that I kind of stay away from
like the kind of single page app push
State stuff because I think no matter
how bad I handle memory I know I'm one
navigation away from it all being
cleared and starting again awesome okay
right I'll go away bye bye
okay awesome uh so I'm Safi as I already
mentioned my two passions in life are
data science for social good and open
source software and if you're interested
in learning more about that or the open
source work that I'm doing I'm captain
Sofia on Twitter and github and NPM um
and like MySpace and Friendster and all
the stuff and Sophia don't rocks is my
website so what are we going to be
talking about today I just want to give
you a quick outline of what you guys are
getting yourselves into so first I'm
going to talk a little bit about why we
should care about memory as software
engineers whether you're working in the
client-side with JavaScript or the
server-side I'm going to give you
reasons to think about memory first and
then we're going to talk about what it
means to manage memory and for those of
you who might have computer science
degrees this is going to be a throwback
to your systems or compilers courses so
I'm sorry if I'm bringing up very
horrifying flashbacks right now please
bear with me and then we're going to
talk it all in particular about how
JavaScript manages memory and then we'll
finish it off with how we can write
memory performant applications but what
are some tools and techniques that you
folks can use and once all that is done
you will be wizards and witches of
JavaScript after battling the Dark Lord
of memory leaks um so first why do we
care about memory why is memory
important to us as programmers and these
are three very bias reasons that I have
for caring about memory the first is
that it forces us to be more inventive
programmers I always think it's great to
add restrictions to the way that we
develop our software because it forces
us to reason critically of our our
applications to analyze and debug things
and use tools like the chrome dev tools
and to build better there's no way to
get somebody more creative and inventive
than by locking them in a dark room or
by placing them in the middle of the
Sahara in 100
degree weather with no Wi-Fi and having
them code ask me about that later
memory is scarce and although the amount
of memory that's available on machines
has been increasing over the past couple
of decades so have people's expectations
of what their machines can do your users
expect your applications to be able to
handle their multitasking workflows
users expect and deserve really rich
interactive web experience and those
things tend to be really memory
intensive and then finally it helps us
exercise our empathy muscles I view
empathy as a muscle that you can train
in thinking about the different
conditions that your program is going to
be used in or your application is going
to be used in in the context of memories
a really great way for you to discover
new user stories and start to think
about how your applications being used
so now that we have a couple of reasons
to care about memory management let's go
a brief overview of what memory
management is so if you programmed in C
you are familiar with a paradigm known
as manual memory management what that
means is that you as the programmer had
to allocate memory on the machine using
malloc then you were done with it you're
responsible for freeing it using free
now there's a fundamental issue with
that and it's that this is a huge
cognitive load on you as the engineer
you can imagine in addition to having
top-down missing semicolons and arguing
over where you place your curly braces
and thinking about algorithm design and
software architecture you have this
additional cognitive load of managing
the memory of your application and
actively thinking about it so you can
imagine software written this way has
lots of memory leaks has lots of other
memory related bugs no fun for anybody
and that's where the concept of
automated memory management comes in
it's known as the garbage collector this
is Oscar the Grouch from Sesame Street
um and the garbage collector is really
in charge of finding out where garbage
memory is and then clearing it away and
we'll get into that a little bit later
an automated memory management has its
pros and consequences the first big Pro
really for us as engineers is we don't
have that cognitive load of having to
manage memory on our own the consequence
is that the garbage collector is an
application it's another program that
runs in order to clear your memory so it
does have a performance endurance and
depending on how good your memory
allocator is and what technique it's
using that hindrance might not be as bad
that is still a consequence also so now
we talked about memory management and
we're going to cover it in JavaScript
really quickly is everyone with me so
far oh yeah get hyped so for the rest of
this talk I'm really going to be
focusing on the v8 JavaScript engine um
we're all pretty familiar with it if you
use Chrome that's the thing that's
interpreting and executing your code
you're using node or MongoDB on the
server side it's responsible there so um
sorry for all the other JavaScript
engines who won't be getting any love
from me today but v8 swear it's up so
let's start off by going through the
basic data types in Java Script I'm
going to start off really easy and then
like ramp it up super fast so if you're
boole's right you're trues your falses
your numbers your one two threes any of
your strings your hello worlds and your
man cats and all that and all of these
are the sort of elements in the
JavaScript universe and they can be
combined to form different compounds and
molecules in your application these are
really the basics and where that becomes
relevant is how memory is allocated
memory is allocated in a heap structure
so it looks something like this so the
read node you see there is the root node
this is something like the window object
the root node has edges pointing to
other nodes in this case the blue nodes
and the green nodes the green nodes in
this particular case are your boolean's
your numbers and your strengths those
fundamental elements the blues are
references to those things so this is
what memory looks like it's definitely a
giant heap which is why Jake made that
joke earlier and v8 does something where
allocates memory into six different
spaces or chunks and there's sort of a
method to the madness of why it does
this and we're going to find out why
later I hope I'm keeping you on the edge
of your seats with all this like we'll
find out later try to keep you guys
excited so let's talk a little bit
different kinds of spaces so the first
space is the new space this is where
memory gets allocated when an object is
immediately created objects in the new
space tend to be smaller they're newer
new space your next space is the old
pointer space so if an object is in the
new space and it's a reference to an
object it's not a scalar itself and it's
resided in the new space for a while
it's been actively used it graduates the
old pointer space and if it's not a
reference the scalar graduates to the
old data space and then you have the
large object space this is where you
store giant look-up tables and things
that don't you don't want to fall under
the memory restrictions or the size
restrictions of the new old end of the
new and old space and then you have the
code space the code space is special
because it contains
executable memory memory on your machine
by default is not executable because you
don't want to go around just running
whatever data is on your memory that
would not be good and so items in the
code space are generally get
instructions just-in-time compiled and
then the last space is the map space and
this contains maps property cells and
cell
these are used by the JavaScript engine
and really for the rest of this talk
we're going to focus on two spaces the
new space in the old space so you can
kind of forget about the rest and you
can treat it as like fun stuff you
learned so this point we've allocated
objects in memory they're in our heap
how do we know what to clean and how to
clean it and really the answer and the
basis for this is reach ability memory
is considered garbage when it's no
longer reachable or accessible in your
code this usually tends to be data that
is not reserved for local variables or
function parameters or global variables
if you look back into the heap the way
that we can determine what is considered
garbage is by traversing through our
heap so you can start off at the root
node anything that you can access by
traveling through nodes in the heap is
considered accessible and reachable
things that you can access are not
reachable in their garbage so these two
your out garbage but how exactly does
JavaScript collect garbage or the v8
engine collect garbage we know how the
allocates memory we know what it
considers garbage how does it collect it
and the v8 engine employs something
called stop the world technique for
garbage collection and so what happens
is programs halted like complete stop
and then there's a pause and that pause
there's a moment where the garbage
collector runs and it's a brief short
cycle and that's really to offset that
performance hindrance so you're just
running quick garbage collection cycles
in pauses in between your program this
next step is going to be a perfect
representation of what this means
yes we've all seen this um so if you
remember earlier we talked about the new
space and the old space and so when you
start to go through these garbage
collection cycles the v8 engine has
different approaches to how it collects
garbage in the new space and how it
collects garbage in the old space so
we'll start off by talking about how it
collects garbage in the new space and
and before I go there this sort of idea
of having a different garbage collection
approach to old memory or and to old
data versus new data is known as a
generational garbage collector just
think you're kind of like approaching
the age of your memory in-app
generations and you're treating each one
differently and so let's talk about how
garbage is collected in the new space
and it's a process known as scavenging
and so generally memory and the new
space is collected more quickly than
memory in the old space just because
it's newer
um and what tends to happen is when your
new space is filled the v8 engines going
to go ahead and start a scavenging
garbage collection cycle in the new
space and what happens in this Gavan
process is your garbage collector is
going to go through your entire heap
it's going to traverse it starting from
the route it's going to make copies of
everything that it traverses and it's
going to clear out what was previously
in the new space and so the copies it
has made is everything that it could
reach in a traversal of the heap and
everything that I couldn't reach and
couldn't copy is considered garbage
memory so that's okay now for those of
you are paying attention to how this
technique works you might realize the
fundamental problem with it which is
that it has a very high space complexity
you need to have double the amount of
memory that is the size of your new
space for that copying over
and this might be a kind of
consequential thing but is if you recall
the data in the new space is younger
smaller data so the sort of fact that
you need double the size of the new
space is not that big a deal so if we go
back to our lovely memory heap we're
going to start off at the red root node
and then traverse over to the blue and
then go over to the two blues and then
go over to the greens and our garbage
nodes are never traversed and they're
never each and they're never copied over
and they're just like obliterated into
nothingness and then for the old data
space um there's a different technique
that's gets used and it's the mark and
sweep technique and the mark and sweep
technique works by traversing the nodes
in the heap marking the ones that are
active and then removing unmarked
objects on a regular basis and I know
that was a super cryptic description and
I could like for you guys right now with
an entire discussion on mark-and-sweep
um but I want you to stay my friends I
really hope you do ah so I won't torture
you that way but in all seriousness
mark-and-sweep has a very rich history
in computing and it merits its own 30
minute maybe 45 minute talk if the
organizers will let me but if you guys
just want to grab me during lunch maybe
do it tomorrow because I'm still
jet-lagged but yes I'm happy to talk
about it so at this point you're almost
almost masters of memory management or
JavaScript you have an understanding of
why we care about it what memory
management is in a general perspective
how it works in JavaScript how the v8
garbage collector works now you want to
start to apply these and only the best
way to approach this is to start by
asking yourself two simple questions
which is how much memory is my
application using and you're never going
to get a solid quantified answer for
this because that's not how it works but
you can start to develop ranges you can
start develop metrics with how much
memory you're comfortable with having
your application use and when you
develop these metrics it's important to
consider that your application runs in
the context of other applications so
like all eight gigabytes of memory or
all four gigabytes of memory on a
machine like belong to you entirely
which is sad you're sharing these lots
of other applications if you've seen
people use like 48 tabs in their Chrome
browser and you're like why do you
torture your browser like that you have
to like share memory with all of the
other taps that they have open and the
second question that you want to ask is
how often does the garbage collector
cycle in my application how often does
it run and you can actually find this
out all I don't have pictures of it in
my talk but if you use the chrome dev
tools timeline tab thing that shows all
the stuff that's happening in your
application Jake will explain later you
can actually find when garbage
collection cycles are running in your
application you can determine how
frequently they're occurring that might
be symptomatic of how fast stuff is
allocating in the new space so if you're
like aggressively allocating new memory
and a loop or something like that you
might want optimize that there's like
stuff you can do that brings us to the
right tools for really messy job
debugging memory is no fun like I'm
surprised most of you are still engaged
in this talk way to go good job but good
tools can make it much easier and so the
first awesome tool once again in chrome
dev tools
there's tons of awesome tools and chrome
dev tools mostly because the folks at
Google are building lots of very memory
intense
applications things like Gmail things
like Google Drive and so you know if the
like Google Drive team or the Gmail team
is like and we need tools to like debug
figure out memory in our applications
they'll like go go bug the chrome team
and the chrome team will be all like
alright we're at your service and so the
result is that there's a rich toolset
for inspecting heap allocation and for
examining and profiling our applications
and dev tools yeah that's great for us
as programmers and so this is a snapshot
that I took of the chrome dev tools heap
allocation profiler running on the
Facebook web application and there's
sort of two curious things that I want
to point everyone to which are the
retained size and the shallow size of an
object and you'll see these mentioned a
lot when you start to like independently
research memory management because I got
you so excited about it the shallow size
of an object is the amount of memory
that it holds in and of itself and the
retained size is its size and all of its
dependents if it's pointing to anything
in the heap structure it's all of those
and the chrome dev tools allows you to
see that oh my god there's there had to
be an NPM command and this after load is
talk yay
another great thing about having tools
like NPM available to us is that people
can build utilities to help other
programmers do their stuff and things
better and so we're all happy people as
a particular utility that I want to
showcase here is called heap dump um
heap dump is a JavaScript library that
you can install for node and it allows
you to take a snapshot of your heap at a
particular instance and it's a super
easy to use library it's got a very
simple API there's only like one
function that exports which is write
snapshot what you can do is you can take
a snapshot of your application at a
particular instant and you'll get a file
with a dot heap snapshot
extension and then you can actually load
it into the chrome dev tools profiler
and start to analyze it inside that
really awesome interface that the team
at chrome built instead of reading the
like raw Heath snapshot file don't don't
do that that's not smart
spare yourself the trouble awesome so
I'm going to try and stay on time um
here with four minutes left
I mentioned that I put together a
resource for everyone here today ah that
I will show off now um
awesome okay hopefully everyone can see
this awesome so this is just a
interactive experience that I set up and
it starts off with the very basic
console logging things um and you start
to get familiar with the heap dump tool
in writing snapshots and there are some
questions for you to think about this is
basically a homework assignment so I'm
like I'm like your college ciass
professor that you hated but hopefully
funnier um so I'm going to go ahead and
publish this really quickly so if it
works awesome I'm going to live tweet it
out awesome so this way you guys will be
able to see I can't live code in my
presentation so the least I could do is
like live tweet that'll help right
also
there's probably a typo in that as is
there a typo and all my tweets thank you
for the applause I know that was all of
computation led up to that
um awesome so feel free to check out
that tool there is a link to that github
repository for it so if you have trouble
with it or like you're confused my my
directions or you think there should be
more jokes in there just open up an
issue and I'll address it if you want to
get the slides for this talk they're
available at sofia Rox um there's a talk
section on my website and if you scroll
down you'll see all the good stuff and
finally thanks for being a wonderful
audience thanks to the organizers for
putting this together and for like
bringing us all here I'll try and get a
lot of sleep tonight so I can like
actually communicate and interact with
you people without being jet-lagged
insane but thanks I hope my talk was
like super informative and you took
something away from it or you just like
liked my jokes that's fine too I'll stop
talking now and Jake can come up and
pills